Bob let's take a look at streaming with
Apple making its way into the business
how big of a threat is it people would
say Apple can do no wrong but it doesn't
seem like young people are biting well
look I think you've really gotta get rid
of the streaming label because that's
not what the consumers use the consumers
90 something percent of consumers say I
listen to both the radio and my music
collection at different times for
different reasons there are people that
are replacing CD sales and then their
radio and there's something a little bit
in between called Pandora and
iHeartRadio now i heart radio is mostly
radio stations who are in the radio side
we do a little bit of custom radio that
custom radio is a little different than
than your music collection and I think
the the challenge you have is to analyze
what that means I think what you're
seeing today is you've got Spotify
you've got Apple that are really selling
you your music collection on a
subscription basis but by the way don't
lose sight of the fact that iTunes
downloads are still doing very well and
you're still selling CDs so I think
people are quick to run to whoever's out
there without really taking a close look
at it a study just came out 3% of ink
are listening is to streaming services
in the broadest sense so we shouldn't
get carried away when you look at radio
radio still all listening is about 90%
about 10% is to the digital versions of
it including art radio and Pandora so
and when you look at Apple the challenge
they got is they're probably not going
to get a Spotify user because they
probably already decided spot why would
I why would I fire Spotify for Apple so
I think the challenge they have is to
convert more of their iTunes download
folks to a subscription service ok then
what's the challenge for advertisers if
I'm an advertiser and Bob Pitman is
saying when they're stopped using they
weren't streaming and there's other guys
saying you're streaming the future and
digital is what you need
where are they going their heads must be
spinning well look I think at the end of
the day that radio is digital if it were
invented today it would certainly be in
the digital category imagine this no
data charge and no buffering what a
marvelous frequency the consumer doesn't
know the difference between cellular
frequency and FM frequency I don't know
and exactly nor mother white nor do I
and nor do I care I think the big
difference between the two is
how the advertising's bought and sold
and radio has traditionally been sold
the way TV was sold the way it's been
sold forever
the challenge is to go to an automated
selling process the way the digital
players you the way the digital players
use it and we're in the process of doing
that and I think others are as well and
I think people in TV are doing it that's
the way the business is going and I
think digital has a an advantage mainly
because of the way it's bought and sold
if you think about it from an
advertising standpoint there are two
things you look at measure ability and
impact and we went way to the extreme of
measure ability I think now we're
beginning to look at ROI and advertisers
are beginning to say wait a minute what
did I get back for the dollar I spent
regardless of how I measured where I
spent it in what you've delivered and I
think that is we see it in the world I
think that's probably the biggest issues
that we're dealing with there was a day
that there were a handful of major
record labels with a handful of
influential producers who would decide
essentially who the next hit maker would
be who is that today who decides in the
next Taylor Swift in this new world
by the way ultimately the consumers and
the reason music gets to the consumer
by the way radio we use radio is the way
people discover their new music 73% of
Americans say the main way to discover
new music second radio the question is
where did radio hear it in my days at
MTV we couldn't break a record but we
could tee it up so that radio could see
oh this one and then they'd play it
today we look at youtube we look at
Shazam we look at a lot of places they I
here's one we should take a chance on by
the way the record companies spend an
enormous amount of their money with
radio promotion staffs they have
research they have case studies they are
in whatever songs they think are at
their am working for the radio airplay
Bob David gave you a lay up the answer
was Ryan Seacrest's right on the
texting let's just walk through winners
and losers pendo are gonna go away as
pinned or I'm gonna get thought look
whether they get bought or not I think
the service is a good service because
what they really are is an easy way to
make a playlist is most of us don't have
time to search through thousands of
songs to find the perfect 200 and you
put a song in and it spits out a
playlist 40 we do the same with our
custom feature of iHeartRadio and there
are others doing it but Pandora led the
way on that but once Apple gets their
groove on no one knows me they're in I
am in the Apple's ecosystem we all are
more than anyone once Apple says I'm
gonna crack into your brain hello they
know how to make it happen but it's
interesting it's a UH you know look I
won't take anything away from Apple but
Spotify was their first with really the
subscription service Pandora is not
doing what Apple's doing that's really a
different kind of service and I think
you have to acknowledge that I think the
competition for Apple is CDs iTunes
downloads and Spotify what happens to
title jay-z's cool and everything but
look the title is also trying to get a
run of it in the days in which we sold
CDs they had many record stores you
didn't just have Tower Records or virgin
records and I think it's logical to
expect they're going to be many
different players by the way I think
it's great for the music business to
have a lot of players because the money
the artists get and the money the record
companies get is the rate they get times
the volume the more players the more
volume to a man who truly celebrates the
artistry